[Musik]
kostenlose schnelltests für alle soll es
ab heute eigentlich bundesweit geben
tatsächlich sind sie aber schwer zu
bekommen
die union und der ärger über die masken
profiteure die abgeordneten löbel cdu
und nüßlein csu treten aus ihren
parteien aus und frontalangriff aus dem
exil die ex royals mägen und harry
werfen der königsfamilie rassismus vor
nennen aber keine namen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg genannt und willkommen
zum nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
montag norbert lehmann ist auch dabei
für den sport ein verwunderter familie
ein hauch von alltag war heute
mancherorts zu spüren offene geschäfte
und belebte sportplätze öffnungs
schritte trotz steigender corona zahlen
damit das nicht nach hinten losgeht
haben bund und länder bei ihrem treffen
vor fünf tagen beschlossen
neben den impfungen auch kostenlose
schnelltests anzubieten
ab heute hat jeder anspruch auf einen
pro woche die kosten trägt der bund
getestet wird durch geschultes personal
in apotheken arztpraxen oder in
testzentren die allerdings müssen die
bundesländer zum teil noch einrichten
und auch sonst sind noch viele fragen
offen christoph distel hat details
monsheim rheinland pfalz hier im neuen
testzentrum bohren die helfer angenehm
und tief und sind auch sonst recht stolz
auf ihr aus dem boden gestampfte angebot
einfach vorbeikommen personalausweis
zeigen nichts zahlen viertelstunde
warten und das ergebnis schwarz auf weiß
haben sowas kommt vielen gut gelegen um
auch so schnell wie möglich wieder an
öffentliche leben teilzuhaben
beruflich bin ich ganz gut mit alten
leuten in kontakt hier ist er also der
von der regierung versprochene eine
kostenlose schnelltest pro woche aus dem
sogar 23 werden dürfen wenn der hals
öfter kratzt es gibt kein
kontrollmechanismus es gibt weder einen
stempel noch irgendeinen einen gutschein
oder berechtigungsschein sondern hier
wird wirklich bundesweit an das
verantwortungsbewusstsein der
bürgerinnen und bürger appelliert klingt
fast zu schön und einfach wenn alle
bundesländer schon so weit wären die
rheinland pfalz mit seinen 300
testzentren sind sie nicht überhaupt ist
noch vieles theorie bei der mission
schnelltest beispiel apotheken da geht's
auch verspricht die regierung aber nur
mit extra eingang und extra raum haben
nicht alle in wiesbaden etwa bieten
gerade mal vier apotheken schnelltests
an und warten sehnsüchtig auf klare
vorgaben aus berlin
wir wissen überhaupt nicht wie es geht
also wie die tests gehen schon aber wie
die abrechnung funktioniert können wir
überhaupt schon kostenlose test annehmen
was für regulär hingeht gibt es ergebnis
noch müssen kunden die 30 euro gebühr
vorstrecken und darauf hoffen dass
irgendwann die krankenkasse erstattet
und beispiel wirtschaft testet eure
arbeiter und angestellten selbst gibt
die regierung den unternehmen vor
theoretisch eine säule der neuen test
strategie doch die meisten zögern weil
doch überhaupt nicht geklärt ist wer
hier welche kosten übernimmt
die tests sollen auch voraussetzung sein
für weitere freiheiten
heute gab es schon mal die ersten der
einzelhandel darf unter auflagen wieder
öffnen
ebenso museen galerien und zoos und auch
ein großes hurra gruppen sport im freien
ist wieder
allerdings ist all das abhängig von den
incidents werten und dem jeweiligen
bundesland
michael kruse schlange stehen für das
einkaufserlebnis vor ort in kiel war die
innenstadt heute voll einkaufen ohne
terminen schleswig holstein geht das so
lange der landesweite incidents wert
unter 50 bleibt shopping
frühlingsgefühle nach dem langen
schatten winter total
da habe ich mich auch gefreut ja und
extremisten früher feierabend gemacht
haben willst langsam auch depressiv zu
hause weil das eine total langweilig ist
aber niemanden mehr sehen kann und in
der stadt zu sein ist einfach schön die
ganzen leute zu sehen und einfach
unterwegs zu sein
noch schnell die frühjahrs modelle
einräumen silke baumann machte mit ihrem
schuhgeschäft in kiel im schatten ein
umsatzverlust von 90 prozent
das soll sich ab heute endlich ändern
für die geschäftsfrau kam die öffnung
des einzelhandels überraschend schnell
so surreal ich kann es noch gar nicht
glauben dass wir viele aufgaben und
irgendwie bin ich auch ganz glücklich
wirklich glücklich
in wiesbaden wird ab heute dem corona
spector garaus gemacht in hessen dürfen
die fitnessstudios wieder öffnen
untersagt bleiben aber kurse und der
saunabetrieb einzeltraining mit viel
abstand für den chef der erste schritt
um wirtschaftlich zu überleben
wir haben heute abend zum beispiel 17
uhr keinen termin mehr frei
so versuchen wir aber möglichst vielen
training anzubieten und nutzen jede ecke
aus die wir haben nur wenige kilometer
von wiesbaden entfernten rheinland-pfalz
haben alle geschäfte wieder auf ohne
voranmeldung und da zieht es so manchen
hessen über den rhein nach mainz ich bin
so ein bisschen beunruhigend ich habe
mir das auch geahnt es gibt ein schöner
satz schon mal der oma immer die
haftstrafe wäre wenn sie losgelassen und
es scheint mir auch so ja das ist wie
die abstände egal aber überall dort wo
aufgemacht wird ist die hoffnung groß
auf ein einigermaßen normales
ostergeschäft
deutschland öffnet vorsichtig und
gleichzeitig nimmt die zahl der
neuinfektionen leicht zu das
robert-koch-institut registriert 5011
neue corona fälle innerhalb von 24
stunden das sind 279 mehr als vor einer
woche
34 menschen starben in verbindung mit 19
die inzidenz steigt seit tagen an und
liegt bundesweit jetzt bei 68 lukrative
geschäfte mit masken mitten in der
pandemie die betroffenen
bundestagsabgeordneten der union geraten
immer stärker unter druck
um wie er sagt weiteren schaden von
seiner partei abzuwenden hat der
cdu-politiker nikolas löbel sein
bundestagsmandat mit sofortiger wirkung
niedergelegt und ist aus der cdu
ausgetreten
auch georg nüßlein von der csu hat am
nachmittag weitere konsequenzen gezogen
astrid wiedemeyer nikolas löbel hat sich
bereits komplett aus dem politischen
geschäft zurückgezogen sein
bundestagsmandat zurückgegeben seine
website seinen twitter-account
abgemeldet der csu-politiker nüßlein
dagegen hielt bisher an seinem
bundestagsmandat fest hat bisher nur die
unions fraktion verlassen und ist aus
der csu ausgetreten das präsidium der
csu warf ihm heute fehlen den
moralischen kompass vor fordert weitere
konsequenzen zur niederlegung des
mandats und zur wiedergutmachung
beispielsweise in form einer spende
haben auch die mitglieder des präsidiums
den abgeordneten georg nüßlein heute
noch mal aufgerufen
heftige kritik heute auch von der cdu
solch eine persönliche vorteilsnahme
schade dem parlamentarismus abgeordnete
seien dem wohle des volkes verpflichtet
wenn man an dieser stelle dem nicht
gerecht werden kann muss man
konsequenzen ziehen und das mandat auch
den bürgerinnen und bürgern zurückgeben
opposition und lobbycontrol werfen vor
allem der union vor zu viel nähe zur
wirtschaft zu haben
im moment scheint es so dass das problem
um die korruptionsvorwürfe und auch die
nähe
von abgeordnetentätigkeit und lobby jobs
tatsächlich ein unions problem sind wir
haben derzeit keine anderen hinweise und
deshalb ist die union auch insbesondere
gefragt jetzt zu handeln
das konzentrieren sich alle auf den
bundestag und die abgeordneten da muss
auch aufgeklärt werden da sind
konsequenzen nötig wir stellen uns aber
auch die frage ob auch seitens des
ministerium alles mit rechten dingen
zugegangen ist
einen sonderermittler fördert die
opposition der druck auf die union die
affäre um geschäfte mit corona masken
aufzuklären nimmt zu haben mit theo koll
in berlin es ist ja nicht nur die union
die durch dieses verhalten beschädigt
ist oder das stimmt es ist naheliegend
dass viele enttäuschte den
vertrauensverlust auf alle politiker aus
denen werden und dennoch dürfte der
schaden für die union am größten sein
und das nicht nur weil es zwei ihrer
abgeordneten sind die an der krise
verdient haben die probleme im pandemie
management werden ja stellvertretend vor
allem von unionspolitikern festgemacht
kanzlerin gesundheits und
wirtschaftsminister
eu-kommissionspräsident in und die
persönlichen vorteilnahme der beiden
abgeordneten kommt jetzt irgendwie noch
obendrauf die sorge in der union ist
dass sich das negativ bei den beiden
anstehenden landtagswahlen auswirken
wird auch wenn diesmal schon viele
frühzeitig per brief gewählt haben und
von der masken affäre gar nicht mehr
beeinflusst werden in jedem fall hat die
unionsfraktion heute entschieden sich
selbst komplett zu durchleuchten um
sicher zu gehen dass nicht weitere
abgeordnete geldleistungen angenommen
haben dankeschön für diese einschätzung
aus berlin theo koll war dass wenn in
einer pandemie wie jetzt wieder mehr
geöffnet werden soll stellt sich die
frage wie sieht es mit der
nachverfolgung von kontakten aus wenn es
doch zu ansteckungen kommt sind etwa in
der gastronomie immer noch zettel und
listen das richtige mittel
die bundeskanzlerin hatte bei der runde
mit den ländern letzten mittwoch laut
über apps nachgedacht was uns da
erwarten könnte zeigt jan hofer in
geschäften restaurants oder bars checken
sich kunden mit dem handy über einen qr
code ein
wer wo mit wem war wird dem handy
gespeichert und nur im fall 1
infektion an das gesundheitsamt gesendet
dass dann alle kontaktpersonen
informiert
diese idee der digitalen kontakt
erfassung ist nicht neu
der software-entwickler jankos arbeitet
seit monaten an solchen apps bislang hat
sich die politik nicht so richtig dafür
interessiert einen einheitlichen
standard gibt es nicht
es gibt super viele kontakt
datenerfassungssysteme die schon
eingesetzt werden nicht nur bei
gastronomen oder betrieben sondern auch
in zusammenarbeit mit kommunen und mit
städten jetzt will sich die politik auf
einen anbieter festlegen die besten
chancen hat di luca app mitentwickelt
von musiker smudo
bis jedoch eine solche app über eine
schnittstelle mit allen
gesundheitsämtern verbunden ist wird es
noch wochen dauern
es ist auf jeden fall sehr ungünstig
dass wir jetzt heute schon öffnen und
haben eine solche nachverfolgung sap wie
luca app noch nicht am platz dass wir
sehr viel sinnvoller gewesen werden das
jetzt schon überall im einsatz auch der
hotel- und gaststättenverband ärgert
sich dass es noch keine app gibt und sie
nicht öffnen können
wir waren die ersten die geschlossen
wurden sind jetzt die letzten die wieder
raus dürfen
und das muss einfach schneller gehen ob
das jetzt die fa oder die fbs hauptsache
wir kommen endlich da aus den schuhen
und haben schnellstmöglich eine lösung
die öffnungen hat längst begonnen wie
die jetzt wieder ansteigenden kontakte
erfasst werden ist noch unklar
eine bittere erkenntnis zum
weltfrauentag heute die korona krise hat
die benachteiligung und armut von frauen
weltweit teils erheblich verstärkt rund
um den globus protestieren an diesem 8
märz frauen gegen den verlust ihrer
arbeit gegen ungerechte bezahlung gegen
belästigung und gegen häusliche gewalt
das leben unter corona bedingungen wirft
den kampf um gleichberechtigung um jahre
zurück auch in deutschland oder sonne
bald hunderte frauen ziehen durch
münchen um aufmerksam zu machen auf die
immer noch fehlende gleichberechtigung
zwischen frauen und männern ungleiche
bezahlung und veraltete rollenbilder
in der heutigen zeit sind wir zwar schon
sehr weit was gleichberechtigung
angelangt aber wir sind halt immer noch
nicht gleichberechtigt in jedem maße für
gleichen lohn zum beispiel für genügend
kindergartenplätze jetzt in corona
müsste man dringend die mitte entlasten
auch andrea reif leiterin einer
werbeagentur und mutter von drei kindern
findet dass es schon vor corona großen
nachholbedarf in sachen
gleichberechtigung gab die pandemie habe
die ungleichheiten noch verstärkt denn
mütter müssten die hauptlast bei der
familienbetreuung tragen
ich habe mich eigentlich immer im
zwiespalt seit einem jahr ich glaube
dass es emotional auch mit es schwierig
so dass man das gefühl hat man wird
nichts mehr gerecht aus dem wir selbst
schon ganz lange nicht mehr aus mir
meinen eigenen bedürfnissen aber auch
eben nicht den bedürfnissen meiner
kinder meiner familie und meiner kunden
ständig muss andrea reisch jonglieren
zwischen home office homeschooling und
haushalt als eigener chef hat sie das
glück ihre zeit flexibel einzuteilen
andere frauen können das nicht experten
fürchten dass nach corona die karriere
vieler frauen zum stillstand kommt dass
sie durch die langen unterbrechungen in
niedriger bezahlte tätigkeiten kommen
dass sie teilweise auch den job und die
tätigkeiten verändert haben das von
daher ihre lohnentwicklung ihrer
karriereentwicklung gebremst wird und
das dann dieses loch auch in der rente
der zukunft deutlich sichtbar sein wird
an diesem symbol tag wünschen sich viele
frauen weltweit dass es trotz corona
vorangeht mit der gleichstellung von
frauen und männern politisch auf dem
arbeitsmarkt und in den köpfen der
menschen
der weltfrauentag ist auch dafür da
immer wieder zu zeigen wie weit wir von
gleichberechtigung entfernt sind in
unserer zdf heute app finden sie eine
interessante analyse hierzu von
gehaltsunterschieden bis hin zum
frauenanteil und erforschen
der tod des schwarzen george freund
hatte nicht nur in den usa wut und
beschmutzung ausgelöst jetzt hat der
prozess begonnen
hauptangeklagter ist ein ehemaliger
weißer polizist der bei flirts festnahme
minuten lang auf dessen hals gekniet
hatte ihm drohen bis zu 40 jahre haft
george clooneys tod hatte wochenlang
landesweite massenproteste ausgelöst
auch vor prozessbeginn gingen viele
menschen gegen rassismus auf die straße
über die zustände im britischen
königshaus wird oft spekuliert eine
vermutung ist dass ist hinter der
fassade des buckingham palace ziemlich
brodelt bislang hat der innersten zirkel
um die queen dazu meist eisern
geschwiegen jetzt haben enkel harry und
seine frau mergen ihrem frust luft
gemacht im us fernsehen bei talk ikone
oprah winfrey
dabei ging es auch um selbstmord
gedanken und um rassismus vorwürfe gegen
das königshaus andreas stamm berichtet
geben allein ihre sicht auf den aufstieg
und fall als sarastro paar vorwürfe der
palast etwa habe sie nicht vor
rassistischen anfeindungen der
britischen presse schützen wollen im
gegenteil im innersten familienkreis
explizit ausgenommen wurden nur die
queen und prinz philip
seit das paar auf rassismus gestoßen es
wurden bedenken geäußert die dunkel die
hautfarbe unseres sohnes sein würde
am ende wollte ich einfach nicht mehr
leben ihr flehen um psychologische hilfe
sei vom palast abgetan worden
gleichgültig neidisch verlogen sei das
königshaus dem paar größtenteils
gegenüber getreten was letztlich zu
harry und megans rücktritt als freund
geführt habe ich fühle mich von meinem
vater prinz charles hängen gelassen er
hat etwas ähnliches durchgemacht kennt
den schmerz sie ist sein enkel die
wunden sind tief das königshaus hat über
die jahre viele stürme überstanden aber
wohl niemals bezichtigte sie jemand als
rassistische institution dass man
psychische probleme nicht ernst nehmen
würde
aus dieser sache kommt die monarchie
kommt niemand raus raus sind harry und
megan neues zuhause in ellund neues
glück verrieten sie noch ihr zweites
kind werde ein mädchen komme im sommer
ein happy end für ihre familie doch für
die königliche war dieses interview wohl
eine kriegserklärung der schaden fürs
königreich sei ihnen egal so kritiker
hätten hätten sich für ein leben als das
in amerika entschieden und dieses
interview habe ihren marktwert dort
enorm gesteigert die queen hatte
übrigens vorab schon wissen lassen dass
sie sich das interview nicht ansehen
wird jetzt die achtelfinal rückspiele
dortmund tritt morgen abend zu hause
gegen sevilla an
das hinspiel in spanien das hatte ja der
bvb 3 2 gewonnen der erste
viertelfinaleinzug in der königsklasse
seit 2017 also zum greifen nah
selbstbewusst gehen sie die aufgabe an
dank vier siegen in den letzten fünf
spielen vor freude bei kapitän marco
reus
jetzt haben wir morgen ein riesen spiel
vor uns wo wir natürlich eine runde
weiter kommen wollen fürs viertelfinale
kann selbst eine knappe niederlage
reichen die dortmunder vertrauen vor
allem auf den turner von airlink holup
zwölf treffer schon 2021 die verletzung
vom letzten samstag scheint auskuriert
berlingen der stand heute schon mit uns
auf dem trainingsplatz
dem geht es soweit ganz gut der schlag
beeinträchtigt da jetzt nicht durchaus
attraktiv auch die prämie der uefa für
das erreichen der nächsten runde 10,5
millionen euro
im weltsport beginnt ein besonderer
wettlauf für die olympischen spiele in
tokio
wer kann seine möglichen athletinnen und
athleten schneller impfen
die chancengleichheit die droht dabei
auf der strecke zu bleiben befürchten
einige im deutschen themen die sehnsucht
nach den spielen in tokios genauso groß
wie die sehnsucht geimpft zu werden die
zeit ist knapp an welchem zeitpunkt wäre
es dann ethisch vertretbar und auch in
ordnung zu sagen so jetzt sind auch
sportler dran im deutschen spitzensport
gibt es keine im privilegierten der
dfb-präsident wir akzeptieren die
festgelegte reihenfolge und werden uns
nicht vordrängeln viele länder handeln
anders beispiel mexiko das olympia team
steht dort auf der gleichen stufe wie
das ärzte personal und wird jetzt
geimpft und es läuft komplette zeit weg
es ist nicht mehr lange bis wir nach
japan abreisen auf ein im zeitfenster
weist der deutsche kanu präsidentin die
impfung muss in einer phase der
trainings ruhe erfolgen um das durch die
intensive olympia-vorbereitung
beanspruchte immunsystem nicht zu sehr
zu belasten
die impf diskussion ist im vollen gange
der ruf nach mehr impfdosen auch große
ehre für zdf sportreporterin claudia
neumann sie erhielt den marie juchacz
frauen preis für ihre verdienste um die
gleichstellung von mann und frau claudia
neumann kommentierte als erste frau ein
spiel bei einer fußball em der männer
bei uns im zdf klasse kollegin freuen
wir uns und gratulieren natürlich sehr
herzlich ein tief von der nordsee bringt
morgen regen schnee und glatte straßen
ab wochenmitte wird es dann stürmisch de
details hat gleich katja horneffer die
kollegen von wiso testen gleich die
korona selbsttests und im heute journal
um viertel vor zehn freut sich marietta
slomka ob sie alles gute ihnen danke für
ihr interesse und bis morgen wenn sie
mögen
[Musik]
die namen meine damen und herren
strahlender sonnenschein im norden wurde
von strahlendem sonnenschein im süden
getrennt durch ein schmales wolkenband
das braucht ein bisschen nieselregen vor
allen dingen aber auch schneeflocken mit
für uns interessant ist auch dieses
wolken gebiet über der nordsee darunter
verbirgt sich das tief ingo und das
bringt uns heute nacht erst mal regen
später dann auch immer mehr schnee zb in
bremen oder in der lüneburger heide
machen sie sich heute nacht also auf
gefährlich glatte straßen zwischen
nordfriesland und dem sauerland gefasst
im süden und im osten ist es zum teil
klar und da sinken die temperaturen dann
auf minus 4 bis minus sieben grad die
höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 2 grad im westerzgebirge und 9
grad am rhein
und schon am vormittag zieht dieses
kleine schneeregen die ich weiter nach
südosten am längsten freundlich bleibt
es noch im süden von bayern und baden
württemberg
am nachmittag gibt es dann diese schnee
regenfälle auch im thüringer wald
vielleicht sogar im erzgebirge am
freundlichsten wird ist am morgen
nachmittag an der ostseeküste
da scheint die sonne sogar strahlt am
rhein und westlich davon da bleibt wohl
beim regen am mittwoch wird ist in
mitteleuropa und auch in deutschland
erstmal ruhig sein aber am donnerstag
kommt da in einen sturm bei temperaturen
von sechs bis 14 grad